-Thank you so much.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have comedy.
We have celebrities.
We have music.
We have a full audience tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
That's right -- there's a heat
wave all across the Northeast,
and even weather people
can't hold back
how they feel about it.
-If you haven't been
outside yet, it's gross.
-It feels really sticky.
-It is thick.
-Today's probably gonna be
a two-
or three-T-shirt type of day
-It's pretty soupy out there
-Brandon, I know you like
to call it split pea soup.
-It's gross.
-Swampy.
-Moist.
-Ew!
-Wow!
Soupy, yeah.
That's also how most peopl
describe their first
post-pandemic handshake.
They're like,
"Are we doing that?"
Swampy, moist, and eww.
It sounds like
Rudy Giuliani's law firm.
-Hey! Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right --
it was so hot today,
I was sweating more than
Trump's zipper.
That's right -- this weekend
former President Trump
spoke at North Carolina's
Republican convention,
but all anyone's talking about
is the way his pants looked.
Check out what's going on
with his midsection.
It's like he's wearing a fanny
pack on the inside of his pants.
It's just...
It looks like he bumped
into something,
and his pants
deployed an airbag.
You know what I'm saying?
By the way, since when
do pants have gills?
Did you see -- What is that?
How do you even --
How do you have to sit
to get wrinkles like that?
It's like you got to be --
You have to have, like,
your legs on your shoulder
or something.
A lot of people
are saying it looks like
his pants are on backwards
Well, it's already inspire
a new ad. Watch this.
-At the Men's Wearhouse, we've
always offered the finest suits,
the best tailoring,
and the sharpest styles,
which is why we're proud
to introduce the...
Zip up the back
and face the day.
-There you go, yeah.
He guarantees it.
-He guaranteed it.
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, this is exciting.
Jeff Bezos just announced
that, next month,
he'll be flying
aboard his company's
first manned rocket to space
Yep. Bezos will be
the first person in space
to look down and say,
"I actually can
see my house from here."
Yeah, after the country
reopened,
most people bought a new bathing
suit, maybe some hard seltzer.
This guy buys James Bond
and a ticket to space.
That's right --
Bezos says it's perfectly safe
because he's being packed
by the same people
who ship Amazon boxes.
By the way,
those are the same pouches
Trump uses in his front butt
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ As Trump ]
Hold on, I can fit --
I think I can
fit two more in there.
Hold on.
Alright, ready. Here we go
-Front butt.
-Bezos will only be in space
for about 11 minutes,
which means, for 11 minutes,
Elon Musk will be like,
"I am finally the richest ma
on Earth, Earth, Earth, Earth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
For 11 minutes.
Well, everyone is
still talking about how boring
the fight was last night between
Floyd Mayweather and Logan Paul.
If you missed it,
you can see all the highlights
by Googling
"Men hugging for money."
The result was a draw,
so the only loser
was everyone who paid 50 bucks
to watch a fake fight.
And did you guys see this?
In a recent interview,
candidates running
for mayor of New York City
were asked about their
favorite New York movies.
And Eric Adams -- his answer
caught people's attention.
Check this out.
-"Serpico."
-"Do the Right Thing,"
Spike Lee.
-"Taxi."
"Are you talking to me?"
-Yes.
-[ Laughs ]
That was the name of the movie
and that's the favorite line
"Taxi."
"Are you talking to me?"
[ Laughs ]
"Taxi Driver," yes.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's the fastest
anyone has ever won
and then immediately lost
my vote.
I was in "Taxi."
-Yeah.
-That should be
your favorite film.
Robert De Niro,
who is on our show tonight
was in "Taxi Driver."
-Yeah.
-I was so psyched.
I'm like, "What?!
This guy's awesome."
Listen, whoever is running
for mayor in Boston
better say "Fever Pitch."
That's all I'm saying.
"My favorite is
'Pitch Perfect.'"
Some business news.
I saw that, for a limited
time this summer,
Bud Light is launching
new spiked-seltzer icicles
Take a look at these things.
Ooh.
Yeah, it's already being
called the easiest way
to accidently get
your toddler drunk.
Well, I don't know
who this is actually for,
but Nathan's is
now selling vegan hot dogs
-Ew!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not saying they're bad,
but Joey Chestnut
couldn't finish one.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Generally speaking,
you're probably not
that health conscious,
if anything in your diet
is in tube form.
I just wanted to say
"tube form."
-Yeah.
-Hey, I saw the that
Royal Caribbean just announced
that they will set sail
from U.S. ports
beginning next month
and vaccines won't be
required for passengers.
-Ooh!
-In related news,
Royal Caribbean
will soon be
quarantining 1,000 people.
You know you messed up
when Carnival
is suddenly the classy
cruise line, you know?
But this is exciting,
'cause if you survive
being unvaccinated
and eating from the buffet
you will be
declared legally invincible.
Well, listen to this.
Organizers
of Philadelphia's
Naked Bike Ride
announced that riders will
still be required to wear mask
at this year's ev--
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay.
-So now it'll be even weirde
when you recognize a coworker.
"Hey, Bill!
I mean, uh...
Happy 70th, by the way.
Be careful of that
bike chain, buddy."
[ Imitates clicking ]
I thought there were basebal
cards in the spokes, yeah.
-Oy!
[ Cymbal crashes ]
Tire pump!
-And, finally,
speaking of being naked,
a woman in Florida went vira
after she stripped down
and trashed
an Outback Steakhouse.
The manager was like,
"Hey, what do you think this is,
an Applebee's?
Come on."
♪♪♪♪
Last night was the season
premiere of "The Bachelorette.
-Whoo!
-Yeah.
I'm pumped for this season
'cause we get to see peopl
spreading viruses
the old-fashioned way.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
After a year locked inside
viewers were like, "You know
hooking up with 30 strangers
doesn't seem so crazy anymore.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. "The Bachelorette"
is back and everyone's fired up.
But you just got to remember
it's a staged show
that's mostly fake,
kind of like a boxing matc
between Floyd Mayweather
and Logan Paul.
So just know that.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Know it going in.
[ Laughter ]
-♪♪ Are we done forever? ♪♪
-You see this?
At one point,
they introduced a contestant
named Connor B.
with a short video,
and it's pretty interesting.
Well, you tell me if you think
it's interesting. Watch.
[ Playing "Chopsticks" ]
♪♪♪♪
-I'm Connor B.
I am 29 years old, and I'm
from Nashville, Tennessee.
Eighth graders,
I'm going to miss you guys
My main occupation
is a math teacher.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, what?
-After that bath video,
I think it's safe to say
he "was" a math teacher.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Yep, Connor might not
find love,
but his substitute just foun
a full-time job, so...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Vocalizes ]
-I'll send a ukulele
in the bathtub.
-Get this. Another contestant,
Cody, listed his job --
check this out --
as zipper sales manager.
[ Laughter ]
Wait, a zipper salesman
and he's single?
[ Laughter ]
-Lots of ups and downs
on that job, you know?
-What's that?
-A lot of ups and downs
on that job.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-If that wasn't strange enough
another contestant said that h
was a surgical skin salesmen
[ Audience ohs ]
'Cause if there's one thin
women love to hear
on a first date, it's, "Well
I sell human skin. Hiya."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
"The Bachelorette" is back
and even though
it was the first episode,
things got pretty intense.
The emotions on that show
can be a little hard to handle
sometimes,
so I thought we could help
Here's a clip from the episode
re-voiced with the least
emotional person we know, Siri
This is "Let's Get Siri-ous.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's get Siri-ous.
-I don't like you, bro.
Like, I've never liked you
and that's fine.
We don't have
to talk at all, bro.
Right. Right. And it's not
my fault I don't like you, bro
You know, bro, you don't lik
me, so that is your fault.
I'm like, "What are you
talking about, dude?"
I'm literally just telling you
exactly what's up, bro.
That's it.
Alright, man.
I don't agree with anythin
that you said,
but okay, that's fine, man
Bro.
I don't think there was a need
for that at all, bro.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?
And in more "Bachelor" news,
today ABC announced
that Chris Harrison is
officially exiting the franchise
after 19 years.
[ Audience awws ]
Yep, Harrison knew there was
trouble when the producers
brought his suitcase
to the meeting.
"No, you're kidding."
[ Laughter ]
It's going to be awkward in th
finale when the limo drive
lowers the partition
to reveal it's Chris Harrison.
[ Laughter ]
Right now he's editing
his résumé like,
"Matchmaker with 19 years
experience
and 3 successful couples?
[ Laughter ]
Give or take.
Two successful couples?"
[ Laughter ]
-"-ish."
Some political news --
Lester Holt sat down with
Vice President Kamala Harris
for an exclusive interview
and when he asked why she hasn't
visited the border yet,
you could tell that she didn't
quite have an answer prepared.
Listen to this.
-Do you have any plans
to visit the border?
-At some point.
You know --
We are going to the border
We've been to the border.
So this whole -- this whole --
this whole thing
about the border,
we've been to the border.
We've been to the border.
-You haven't been to the border.
-And I haven't been to Europe.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that escalated quickly.
That's right.
Harris was not in the mood
Don't be surprised
if you see Lester Holt
narrating his own episode
of "Dateline."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Holt ]
It started out
as a normal interview.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, it was just announced
that former President Trump is
launching a speaking tour
with Bill O'Reilly
[ Audience groans ]
called The History Tour.
[ Laughter ]
When he heard,
Sean Hannity was like,
"Well, I met someone new
and totally awesome, too,
so, um."
[ Laughter ]
It should be a fun tour.
Backstage passes
automatically come
with a hush money payment
of $130,000. Isn't that nice
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I read that the CDC issued
a warning that salmonella
has been linked to some
breaded chicken products.
With chicken sandwiches
at stake,
even conspiracy theorists
were like, "Vaccines, now!
[ Laughter ]
Put the Bill Gates in me!
Let's go!
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to Popeyes!
[ Laughter and applause ]
You're not stopping me!
I'm going to Popeyes!
Give me the 5G!"
[ Applause ]
Some fashion news --
Balenciaga just unveiled
its new stiletto Crocs.
Here's a photo.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great way
to be comfortable
and uncomfortable
at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, stiletto Crocs,
or, as strippers call them
business casual.
[ Laughter ]
Give it up for your dancer
Herman!
♪♪♪♪
[ Vuvuzela blasts ]
-Stiletto.
-And finally, a pizzeria
in Rhode Island
just introduced a new employee
Watch this.
-The robot, named Servi,
is now tending to customer
at Angelo's Palace Pizza.
So far, she's been a big hit
with many customers
requesting a table
in Servi's section.
She can chat with guests
and even wish them
a happy birthday.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And just like a real server,
Servi waits
until the exact moment you tak
a huge bite before asking,
[ Robotically ]
"How's everything tasting
over here?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, it's a great innovation
especially when
the last customer leaves
and Servi becomes Moppi.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today President Biden flew
to Europe
for his first foreign trip
as president.
Yep, Biden's going to England,
Belgium, and Switzerland.
And he won't come home
until he finds
a new host for "The Bachelor."
That's right --
Biden is hoping to repair ties
with our European allies.
I think he'll be well-received
I mean, for starters, ther
won't be a giant baby balloo
following him wherever he goes
And this was crazy.
The plane carrying
White House reporters to Europ
was delayed for several hour
due to mechanical issues
caused by cicadas.
United was like,
"Ooh, that's good.
Could we use that?"
Even Biden had some
cicada trouble of his own
here this morning, swatting on
away before his flight.
Look at this.
[ Laughing ]
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
-Whack!
-Tomorrow, that cicada will be
on Fox News in a neck brac
calling for Biden
to be impeached.
"See what he did to me?
It's on tape."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The cicada returned
to his buddies like,
"Damn, the old man's
quicker than I expected."
Meanwhile, Mike Pence was like
"Bugs on your head?
You're supposed to save that
for the big debate."
Come on.
Speaking of the president,
right now,
he's trying to meet his goal
of getting 70% of America
vaccinated by July 4th.
And that's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
We can do it.
And that's not all.
Biden has other goals
that he thinks
that we can accomplish, as well.
For instance,
he plans on getting...
Yeah.
He'll also make it so...
K.
Up next...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know what I'm saying?
Back to my high school weight.
Oh, my gosh.
Also...
That would be fantastic.
And, finally...
These are all goals.
You need goals.
Well, get this -- to celebrate
the 4th of July,
France is sending the U.S.
a second Statue of Liberty
that's 1/16 the size
of the original.
Yeah, France is getting us the
same gift they already got us.
In other words, they're alread
in the Father's Day spirit
It's like, "Wow, a tie.
I think I have that."
First, France gave us
a 150-foot statue
and now a 9-foot statue.
In a few years,
they're just going to give u
a commemorative Monopoly piece
I saw that
IRS Commissioner Charles Retti
testified
on Capitol Hill yesterday,
and he kept using
the word "stimmy"
to refer to stimulus checks.
Stimmy.
Watch this video.
-The scope, if you will,
of outreach
for the IRS
has greatly expanded,
really as a result
of EIP1, -2, and -3.
The stimmies have been
fantastic for us,
in terms of getting
into the communities.
-Yeah.
[ As Rettig ] The stimmies
The stimmies
have been fantastic.
He didn't stop there.
After that, he said...
-Wow!
-He said that.
And he kept going.
Then he was like...
-Wow! The head of the IRS.
-He said, "Not cheugy."
-Not cheugy. Wow!
-#NotCheugy.
-Yeah, and then, finally,
he ended up by saying...
"Sheeeesh!"
Did you guys see this?
During a climate
hearing yesterday,
Republican Congressman
Louie Gohmert
suggested some
alternative solutions
to fight global warming.
Listen to this.
-Is there anything that th
National Forest Service
or BLM can do
to change the course of th
Moon's orbit
or the Earth's orbit
around the Sun?
Obviously, that would have
profound effects on our climate.
-I would have to follow up
with you on that one,
Mr. Gohmert.
[ Laughter ]
-His next question was --
[ As Gohmert ] Can anyone
tell me where I am right now
She was like,
"I'll listen to your idea,
but maybe we start
with no plastic bags,
and then we'll reverse
the Earth's orbit.
You know 'Superman' isn't
a documentary, right?"
Some entertainment news.
This week,
the Cannes Film Festival
is happening
on the coast of France.
They just announced that the new
"Fast and Furious" movie
will have a surprise premier
at the festival.
They even cut a special
never-before-seen trailer
just for Cannes.
-Really?
-Take a look at this.
-[ Speaking French ]
-Non!
-Interesting.
"Fast Neuf."
-Wow!
-Finally, I read that lobste
prices are increasing
due to limited supply
and high demand.
But it'll be worth all the money
and the hour of labor,
once you get those
two small chunks of meat out
I'm wearing a bib,
and my hands are bleeding.
Isn't this romantic?
Meanwhile, the C.E.O.
of Sizzler was like --
[ Smoker's voice ]
I knew keeping lobsters
in a gray tank for five year
would pay off.
♪♪♪♪
Today President Biden
kicked off his European tour
in the UK
and met with British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson
Yeah, at first, Biden didn't
even recognize Johnson.
He thought he was
a hungover Weasley brother
[ Laughter ]
But Biden and Johnson
are getting a lot done.
Today, they launched
a task force to reopen trave
between the US and the UK.
When they heard that,
Harry and Meghan were like
"You can try all you want...
That's right --
Biden and Johnson are trying
to reopen travel
between the US and the UK,
which is great because it mean
we're one step closer
to Kamala Harris
finally visiting Europe.
-And I haven't
been to Europe.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"I've never been there."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Biden and Johnson
were actually supposed to meet
on a small island before bad
weather changed their plans.
This is the island right there
Yeah.
That's a shame because I love it
when world leaders
hang out at locations
from "Mario Kart."
[ Laughter ]
Did you see that cute island
I mean, come on.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, if Putin invited yo
to a place like that,
you'd be like, "Uh, let's do i
somewhere more public!
Uh, let's go
to the M&M's store."
Yep, Biden and Johnson met
at the site
of this weekend's G7,
and right across the street,
an artist built a sculptur
of the seven leaders
made out of electronic trash
and called it
"Mount Recyclemore."
Take a look at this thing.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
It's kind of sad Trump
couldn't even get his face
on Mount Recyclemore.
You know?
Sad.
That's right.
President Biden spent
the whole day over in the UK
And you know the British hav
some pretty colorful slang
but so does President Biden,
so we thought we'd put togethe
a quick tutorial
on the differences between
how they use certain phrases
For example, first up,
we have
[ English accent ]
"slag off."
To someone in England,
that means...
But for Biden, it means...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Put hot dogs in his pocket
-Ew.
In the shirt pocket.
-Shirt pockets to keep you cool.
-Yeah, to keep you cool.
-Yeah. That's interesting.
-Not cooked.
-Let's look at another example
We have
[ English accent ]
"Bob's your uncle."
The British use that to mean..
But to Biden...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I -- Squirting?
-Like that?
-Interesting.
-With holy water?
-Finally, we have
[ English accent ]
"throwing a wobbly."
To the British, it means..
But to Biden...
Just interesting.
Interesting difference.
Interesting.
[ Applause ]
Hey, this is cool.
I saw that Mattel just announced
its first line of Barbie dolls
made from recycled plastic
That's great, but, honestly,
I feel like they could have done
a better job with the name
I just --
-That's not good.
-That's just odd.
-Yeah.
-Get this.
7-Eleven just announced
that this year,
their free Slurpee giveawa
will not just occur on one day
but for the entire month
of July.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's part of their
94th-birthday celebration,
which means they're almost
as old as the hot dogs
on the rotating grill.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
this is very exciting.
Today Mayor de Blasio announce
that New York City
is bringing back the Macy'
4th of July Fireworks Show
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Of course,
the big fireworks show
will immediately be followed
by the Car Alarm Spectacular
Today in England, the world'
biggest leaders got together
for the start of the G7 Summit
Yeah, it's a meeting
of leaders from the U.S.,
UK, Canada, France, Germany,
Italy, and Japan.
It's basically Epcot
without the day drinking.
This is the first in-person G7
in nearly two years.
And, like everyone else
at an in-person meeting,
they're all thinking,
"This could have been a Zoom
It could have been a Zoom.
In addition to the G7 members,
India, Australia,
and South Korea were invited
as guest countries.
And if they do well,
they get a spot
on the G7 spinoff series
G7 Summit Island.
[ Laughter ]
And like they do every year,
all the G7 leaders got togethe
for a family photo.
Take a look at this. Yeah.
It looks like
a choose your player,
part of a law firm video game.
They had fun on the beach
until Biden asked everyone
to recreate
the volleyball
scene from "Top Gun."
You're like,
"I don't get this."
I read that, during the summit
all G7 leaders
are staying at this castle
[ Oohing ]
Apparently, the world econom
is in such bad shape,
they all had to share an Airbnb.
Yep, seven world leaders all
living in the same house,
while Vladimir Putin
watches from home,
like it's an episode
of "Big Brother."
[ As Putin ]
This is my favorite show.
Get this, ahead of Biden's
meeting next week with Putin
former President Trump
decided
to put out a statement
and it said...
Trump's still banned
on Facebook and Twitter,
so he issued that statemen
by yelling it
at a Wendy's drive-through
That's right, Trump had
to go through Biden
because, you know,
Putin didn't give him
his real phone number.
He's like --
[ As Putin ] Sure, Donald, yes
it's -- Write this down.
1-800-588-2300, yeah.
Empire Today.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is huge.
The National Geographic Societ
has just announced
a new fifth ocean.
It's the body of water
surrounding Antarctica,
and it's called
the Southern Ocean.
So now there's the Atlantic,
Pacific, Indian, Arctic,
and Southern.
It's such big news,
it inspired me
to write a tiny song about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Just a couple of second
of the show I'm hosting ♪♪
♪♪ To give a shout-out
to the brand-new ocean ♪♪
♪♪ Congratulations
on your promotion ♪♪
♪♪ The penguins and the fish
you got a brand-new ocean
♪♪ Ocean mom and dad fille
with proud emotion ♪♪
♪♪ The big blue baby
is a brand-new ocean ♪♪
♪♪ I would've sent a card,
but didn't know the postage
♪♪ Or the address
for the brand-new ocean ♪♪
♪♪ Watching all your waves
kind of like hypnosis ♪♪
♪♪ Going to need a Dramami
on the brand-new ocean ♪♪
♪♪ Protecting you from plast
is my new devotion ♪♪
♪♪ Going to use a metal stra
in the brand-new ocean ♪♪
♪♪ Even though it's cold,
put on your suntan lotion
♪♪ Before you swim
in the brand-new ocean ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Moving on.
Hey, some entertainment news -
last night was
the series finale of "Keeping Up
with the Kardashians."
Yeah, it's hard to say goodbye
Watching people stand
around their kitchen,
looking at their phones,
it felt like watching
our own family.
The show led to nine spinoffs.
Yeah, Kris Jenner is basically
the Vin Diesel of reality TV
Well, listen to this.
I just saw that Netflix
just launched an online stor
that sells show-branded
merchandise.
But this is annoying --
if an item sits in your cart
for too long,
a message pops up that says,
"Are you still shopping?"
Just a thought, though.
If you're watching Netflix
and wearing it, it might be time
to get out of the house.
And finally, a lobster diver
in Cape Cod
is okay after being swallowe
and then spit out
by a humpback whale.
Yeah, the good news is
he's okay.
The bad news is he's being sue
for copyright infringement
by the Bible.